we know the show just started so we're
going to get straight to the point we're
here to present the award for best
animated features
yes
animation but where does one even begin
to adequately capture the magic that is
animated film
that's why we're here so these are the
nominees for best animated
[Music]
um
that word animation like many words it
comes from the mother tongue Latin oh my
God it's root meaning
bestow life Dwayne we just need to keep
this moving because do you see they're
exhausted just even at this Emily is it
yes no we're just wasting time you know
what I mean really think about it is it
really wasting time to say that
animation is a very definition of film
artfully telling sufficient thank you
you know what see that yeah
artfully thank you guys artfully telling
sophisticated narratives frame by frame
that it's tied to the origin of Cinema
itself and encompasses a whole array of
visual Styles and techniques as
displayed by thank you the nominees this
year that was very very nice
thank you very very nicely cooked and
I'm going to give you that one
here are the nominees for best animated
feature film Guillermo del Toro's
Pinocchio yomo Del Toro Mark Gustafson
Gary Unger and Alex Buckley Marcel the
show with shoes on game Fleischer King
Elizabeth home Andrew Goldman Caroline
Kaplan and Paul masse Puss in Boots The
Last Wish Joel Crawford and Mark Swift
the Sea Beast Chris Williams and judge
Slinger turning red domichi and Lindsay
Collins okay
and the Oscar goes to Guillermo del
Torres Pinocchio
[Music]
first saw Walt Disney's Pinocchio as a
child and felt it was the first time
somebody captured how scary childhood
could be wow thank you
it's it's so good to know that that
this art form that we love so much stop
motion is very much alive and well
um I want to thank uh Shadow machine and
the crew up in Portland I want to thank
the Henson company and Lisa Henson I
want to thank my beautiful wife and
Sebastian as well and this man who was
really the Genesis of everything
including my drinking problem
animation is not a genre and animation
is ready to be taken to the next step we
are all ready for it please help us keep
animation in the conversation I would
like to thank Netflix and Ted sarandos
for sustaining his faith and also to
make this movie and I want to dedicate
this to my the love of my life my wife
Kim my kids and my mom and pop they're
not here anymore but they are here with
me and I'm your son and I love you thank
you
foreign
[Music]